good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is have energy over
to you Bill Gates when I started
Microsoft I didn't think of it as all
that risky I mean I was so excited about
what we were doing
it's true I could have gone bankrupt but
you know I had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to you've always got a job with a
bill man and the only the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting and starting
the company was when I started hiring my
friends and they expected to be paid
and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that I counted on to
come through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll even if
we can get in heat any team was coming
in and I'm almost heard about the whole
time we have about 10 billion now which
is pretty much enough for the next year
anyway you know I if you're going to
start a company it takes so much energy
that you know you it better overcome
your your feeling of risk I don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career I think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go lease
premises they made that hard for me you
couldn't rent a car when you were under
25 at the time so I was always taking
taxis to go see customers and the people
would you know people say well we're
going to go have a discussion in the bar
well I go to the bar and I don't that's
fun because I'll tell you when people
are first skeptical and then go this kid
doesn't know anything then when you show
them you've really got a good product
you know something they actually tend to
go overboard and they think whoa you
know they know a lot let's really do an
incredible amount of these people so our
youth at least in this country was a
huge asset for us once we reached a
certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people because they'll
be a little bit conservative about
whether they should come in and take the
risk and it took three or four years
before we could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come up starting to firm
you better think of those as part of the
the pleasure part of the the challenge
that that is part of the excitement
having the energy to be resourceful is
one of the most important criteria that
you need to be as an entrepreneur you
need to have if you are not energetic
and resourceful to solve problems you
are going to fail because it's going to
be so many problems for those of you
who've already started and we were
further along and entrepreneuring you
know what I'm talking about there's
problems up there problems that they're
problems at the problem and I'm an
optimistic positive guy you know I see
through the problems I see the success
and I believe in your success but I'm
also realistic and that there's going to
be tons of problems maybe tons of crap
and I don't believe enough people are
talking about all the problems and crap
that you
to deal with on your path to success and
so you need to have the energy to be
results will to get through it and what
often happens is people finally figure
out something to figure out how their
industry is working they are having
success and then something tweaks
something changes because it's always
going to change an industry doesn't just
stay stagnant forever something changes
in people complain where people get a
problem or they change something people
complain they complain to their friends
that can play maybe to their customers
they complain to the people around them
and that is never the solution you're
never going to win by complaining the
entrepreneurs are the one who see those
changes and see those problems that are
happening the shifts and it feels an
opportunity for them to stand out for
them to figure it out and to win I look
at the recent changes in the YouTube
algorithm as an example since are
watching us on YouTube YouTube is really
focused on promoting people who are
making consistent content they want
daily content if you were producing
high-quality daily content you're going
to win really hard right now in the
YouTube environment and I go to klimer
Khan which is an event for youtubers
with a hundred thousand plus subscribers
and I'm telling people this is this is
how I've been able to win I've been able
to pass people who I think have better
content or better channels or better
speakers than I am I've been able to
smoke past them because I'm playing to
YouTube's algorithm better than they are
and a lot of the feedback coming back is
I don't know I can't do it why does
YouTube have to do this and just
complaints I love it like if you guys
don't want to this is a golden era this
is your chance to capitalize were the
bigger players the people ahead of you
are not paying attention or they're
complaining this is your chance to even
if you have worth quality stuff even if
you're not as good or talented as they
are you can start to beat them because
you understand the rules better this
should be exciting for you I wish
YouTube changed their algorithm every
month because when everybody else is
complaining I'd be figuring it out and
starting to win that has to be your
approach as an entrepreneur like where
did Amazon come from Amazon shouldn't
exist
Amazon should have been started by one
nobles and boarders but they didn't pay
attention they thought the internet was
a fad they complained about online sales
and they allowed Amazon to come and eat
up a lot of their business and it
happens it's every single industry no
industry stays the same forever it's
constantly changing disruption is the
friend of the entrepreneur you want
massive destruction in your industry you
want the people above you complaining
about how something is being done
complaining won't make a change and that
change is coming it's coming hard and
it's coming fast and that is your
opportunity when you see people
complaining around you that is your
opportunity to win and so talking to
these youtubers you know I try to give
them advice I try to help them out some
people might take it a lot of people
won't and those guys will start to lose
and people will come out of nowhere and
crush them in their own space because
they just understand how they are grows
and works and so you need to stay on top
of the change unit industry and have the
energy and have the belief system that
every change that come I love it and I'm
going to crush it and it is my
opportunity to win while everybody else
complained so the question is a today is
I'm curious what is one complaint that
you've heard over and over and over
again in your industry that you are
turning into an opportunity for your
business leave it down the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
david Hurley David thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really means a lot to me
man and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
for spray so give me go
you show up at work with the right
attitude and with the positive attention
and I actually had a t-shirt made the
positive energy is a part of your job
description right so the idea that I
want to show what was the right energy I
want to show up you know we're all here
you don't even now we're all here we're
trying to feed our families where we're
trying to have a good time we're talking
out there it's an important part of our
lives our time is all that we have so to
me it's hugely important to deliver
positive energy in a way because it
sparks so and I come to positive energy
that someone else will take out all the
positive energy they can offer your
families and you know so for me it's
just hugely important to approach
everything and everybody at every turn
with these being the most positive
loving kindness that I can generate one
of the things that people talk a lot
about is what gets something to become
an entrepreneur I mean I hear it's just
a fascinating mindset right you really
have to be fighting than usual hard to
be a you know an entrepreneur because
you have to suspend disbelief you only
have to believe about your own idea and
have deep passion you won't pursue it so
in some sense but honestly before I knew
advise I take a lot of inspiration from
what you're doing now it takes a lotta
it takes a lot of energy to be an
entrepreneur and I think that in that in
there they lied I think your secret to
success which is your ability to
overcome every constrain and every
obstacle and not and do it with the
boldness and the risk on nature of it I
think it's fantastic
if anything I would say especially for
entrepreneurs is you gotta keep sustain
that sense of energy
over a long period of time because we
all know and you are grounded in it the
mortality rate is super high and that
means you will be thrown curveballs you
know day in and day out and you have to
be able to overcome that and so being
the source of energy in your small team
especially the CEO of a start-up I like
to sort of observe their millat because
up you can't have a bad day you're all
the time you know you get up in the
morning you're coding in the afternoon
you're talking to your investors
reasoning you're you know hiring and
that constant sense of energy and
passion for what you're doing is what I
think it takes and to never give up
which is what makes you who you are in
terms of the core makeup and I think
that for me I am personally inspired by
all that and I think that's even from a
Microsoft culture that's what we my team
is like it is not that okay we have you
know a large organization my hope is
that every team inside of Microsoft fuse
book that sense of energy and
empowerment and goes about it